if you look over here we can see
um
some typical aerials now this aerial
here which you might just be able to see
is a so-called dielectric aerial which
is um which is designed for bluetooth
applications and so the wavelengths will
be quite long
but we've played some tricks in the
design stage use some dielectric
material and we've ended up with an
aerial which is just a few millimeters
long
so as we walk along i guess
you see aerials everywhere
on the tops and roofs of
almost every building
well we can see we can see a mobile
phone mast on the top of the hospital
we uh we certainly depend on them almost
uh
for our routine daily lives from
everything from uh from a mobile phone
of course
mobile phone there we are everybody
everybody knows what they are
this is the back of the physics uh
building and uh if you if you look at
the you see the dome of the ordinary
conventional
reflector optical telescope but today
we're a little bit more interested in
how these different aerials work
this is the radio telescope
system a single uh radio telescope dish
a radio wave comes in here uh flat
parallel
hits this curved surface and then
bounces off to the focus which is uh the
aerial here so the only aerial in the
system is inside uh that little uh that
little shield there
this uh this aerial is tuned to around
about 1.4 gigahertz
um so that's much higher than the normal
radio transmissions that we're we're
used to hearing but around about the
sort of mobile phone uh transmission
area what this is actually looking at is
is the
um
natural emissions from hydrogen
now if i was to hold a bucket of
hydrogen here
in front of the aerial we wouldn't see
anything at all we wouldn't pick that
signal up because
what what we're looking for is
very very rare spin flip events in the
in the hydrogen itself and that that is
so rare that we would never be able to
detect it here on earth but when you've
got a galaxy right out there
with billions and billions of tons of uh
of hydrogen gas then that's enough for
these rare events to become quite a
large signal
well this racket i've i've been trying
to receive uh my radio station and um
i appear to be getting lots of crackles
on my uh on my radio set i hope you can
uh hope you can hear them put them near
the
microphone there
now
where are they where are they coming
from i've got a good idea let's go and
find
[Applause]
getting
out
just to prove it
you see it went well what's going on in
this uh this piece of kit we've we've
got a um some power supplies so the
electrons are piling up on this on this
little tip uh over here and then when
the voltage is high enough for the um
for the air to break down just like in a
a thunderstorm in a lightning strike
then the electrons will jump across
across that gap
just for a moment
um this is uh this is a single electron
if i have
if i have a charge then that produces an
electric field which radiates out
but
probably where you're standing brady you
probably wouldn't be able to pick up
that electric field from
from there if if my electron is
traveling at a constant velocity
from one end of the tube to the other
we call that an electric current
now of course i'm going to be in trouble
from my physics colleagues because
a real electron doesn't travel that far
it only travels a few microns uh perhaps
in a metal but
this is a good enough this is a good
illustration so
what does that do well that produces a
current of course and
because the current is flowing that
produces a magnetic field around that
but that isn't enough that isn't that
isn't going to produce our radiated wave
what what produces the the wave
is when the electrons start to oscillate
up and down so we have an alternating
frequency
or we could call that an acceleration so
in the smart gap
we had our electrons pretty much
stationary on one side of the one side
of the gap and then suddenly whoop
there
accelerated over the gap
so when you've got an accelerated charge
you've got
not only the electric field radially but
you've also got an electric field
tangentially along the
along the aerial like that
and it's the combination of those two
effects the magnetic field and the
tangential field which produces the
relationship the orthogonal relationship
between the magnetic and the electric
field
that couples to this traveling wave
what happens at the other end is
let's say we've got our we've got our
aerial we've got an aerial here that's
just just a piece of wire
and
inside that wire we've got um we've got
stationary conduction electrons
when a wave
comes in from our transmitter it's not
very good because i'm moving anyway when
the wave comes in
literally it makes those
it makes those electrons move in
sympathy and of course that is a that
means that there is a voltage at the uh
the base of the aerial which i can then
uh then pick up with the electronics and
the receiver inside there okay so why
why are aerials a certain size um
and we've got a
we have an fm
type of aerial and we tune it to local
radio station which is say say 100
megahertz then
we'd expect the wavelength to of that of
that wave to be three meters and
sometimes we refer to wavelengths in in
meters radio waves can uh can occupy a
variety of um
of wavelengths and we only have to look
at our radio uh dial um the seldom used
um long wave of course is literally
means long wave and so radio 4
long wave is actually 1500 meters long
so
what is that that's three and three
quarters round times around the running
track so that's how long the wavelength
is
when we get to um our fm wave band
which is around about 100 megahertz 100
million oscillations of that little
table tennis ball um
per second
then the wavelengths come down to around
about two or three meters um
so what's two or three meters it's that
sort of
length okay
and so the best aerial we actually can
build is when we have a quarter
wavelength so
when that's a quarter wavelength long
we get a good a good antenna
however when we go up in frequency and
we start talking about our mobile phone
type of aerials which are
a couple of gigahertz
so that's 2 000 million cycles per
second
then the aerials can be probably a
little bit smaller so probably the
wavelengths are 10 centimeters
and so we get aerials which are perhaps
a couple of a couple of centimeters
however we can play a few little extra
tricks because you can't see an aerial
on this on this phone
and in point of fact
by
slowing the wave in a so-called
dielectric just like a refractive index
optically
then we can play a few tricks we can
make we can actually make our aerial
effectively smaller by surrounding it
in a block of uh dielectric like a
plastic in in a sense if you look over
here we can see
some typical aerials now this aerial
here which you might just be able to see
is a so-called dielectric aerial which
is
which is designed for bluetooth
applications and so the wavelengths will
be quite long
but we've played some tricks in the
design stage use some dielectric
material and we've ended up with an
aerial which is just a few millimeters
long
this is um a patch antenna which is used
for global positioning system antenna so
that works at about one and a half
gigahertz
and the actual aerial is this square
plate um of
of conductor on the top well those are
so small and that's quite good otherwise
our aerials on our mobile phones would
be bigger than the phone which of course
if you're old enough like me and
remember the first mobile phones of
course they were